and we go to the coronavirus now and
efforts to test clark county school
district staff all unvaccinated ccsd
employees have to take a test every week
this week testing lines and demand in
many cases exceeded capacity we have
bianca holman live this morning at ccsd
headquarters where they've implemented
some changes to try and make things go a
little more smoothly bianca
good morning john so there was a recent
announcement that now allows ccsd staff
to get their testing done at walgreens
cvs and also the health district and
expanding this again will help alleviate
those long lines so definitely an
announcement that was needed so we want
to show you some video of those long
lines that were happening earlier this
week
again it shows the lines at the various
school district testing sites and it
wasn't just a long line some locations
even ran out of kits by the time people
got up to the front calls and emails
flooded the clark county education
association now 41 percent of ccsd staff
have uploaded their vaccine cards and
that's according to ccsd but they expect
that number to go up in the coming weeks
the union is working with county
commissioners to add more testing sites
and make vaccinations more accessible
people are definitely on edge it's
deadly and our educators you know want
to make sure that this is as safe a
return as possible for our students and
educators and so a lot of the emails
were about the frustration of the
delivery method yesterday um you know
with the testing however they understand
the importance of why we need to make
sure that everyone is as safe as
possible
so the system is also a little bit
delayed the district says if you are a
staff member and you uploaded your
vaccination card and still get an email
regarding testing
ignore it you will eventually get a
confirmation email and they also said
that they have actually a vaccine cue
tracker so that you can actually see
and actually a testing tracker testing
site tracker so that you can see just
the amount long of wait that's what's
going to be at the various testing sites
across ccsd so definitely use that so
you can plan ahead and if there's a long
line you can go someplace else reporting
live from saharan decatur bianca holman
8 news now